welcome to this video i'm playing a
poison poison I think from France I've
played by da 396 funny line but why not
and maybe maybe be aggressive in the
center ok that's a bit like the kind
defense oh come on let's let's do
something wacky for a change and attack
him directly ok so the H file is open
that's a good thing a bad thing is he
has a very serious cow to play in the
center um what to do Bishop to h3 well
it's probably not good I would like to
get the Queen over 2h fire obviously but
not not really easy to accomplish
now I don't like to do that but I cannot
really allow him to take himself maybe
Bishop e6 Queen d7 this kind of ideas
okay yeah he can leakin yeah he gets
quick play in the center of course when
I decided to play age five and you that
this was going to be a bit shaky or it
might get to get a bit a bit wild but
you played this well yeah going for play
in the center quickly but here I can
take you isn't this okay for me yeah
it's not fantastic but I should be able
to to play this position sack now it
takes yeah we get we got lots of trades
and at the end I should be active enough
9494 Bishop e7 yeah that that's okay I
mean I'm I'm very active in the center
so it's not not a problem that my pc 6
bond is weak i have looked it to for
example yeah that's a good at game
because my king is in the middle that
went went rather well on not yeah it's
not a bad idea it also fixes the pawns
on the light square as a bit makes it
more difficult time to move them
that's very accommodating now we're even
a bishop endgame is very very promising
the king when the King can invade to 2d
four and so on check maybe I should have
played g5 first but okay if he goes f F
for now okay doesn't I get equity play
g5 as well
he it's not really able to move to move
a lot here the very very passive
position
rook be one is almost almost a win but
you can take and play King detune and
now we cannot do that so this is just a
win right yeah this is just winning I
get to see three and then pick up the
whole Queen side
it does not matter really I can also
take a form check check check check
check check you're really playing the
song ok white resigns yeah that that
that was really bad transformation into
the end game where black was immediately
more comfortable it it seems that
probably you should play a slower move
like maybe could not be three or
something this instantly leads to
problems away ms the tactic i miss the
tactic this one very nice tactic
intending lightly to checkmate wow
that's cute ok ok i only saw that this
is a good end game that's quite funny
the engine is just on minus 0.2 which is
of course far far too low but black is
substantially better here of course with
the with the activity and everything ya
know it it goes much higher so the this
is the the move that definitely allows
an easy win if it does not do that i can
I can go here but that's a bit more
complicated than just exchanging looks
and picking up the whole Queen side so
maybe he also should avoid the
immediately form and just continue
normally also there is c4 which is a
good idea yeah but this is a really cute
tactic here with Josh absolutely I mean
you're sort of pre move this stuff yeah
but this is really nice with 92
checkmate okay thanks for watching